hello everyone and welcome to a very
nice game from the 2012 Grand Slam chess
tournament in Bilbao it's a game between
Fabiano Khurana and Magnus Carlsen as
the World Chess Championship is almost
here I decided to check up on some of
their older games and this is a very
nice and a very significant game for
reasons I will only later reveal now
sorry about that pull a cropped board in
my previous video I have no idea how
that happened
III don't think it had to do anything
with my interface I I think Chad comm
updated their interface so it interfered
with with my setup but I think
everything is in order now and a lot of
you said that you enjoyed that I added
the ratings in that engine match
stockfish versus komodo so I decided to
leave it here although I'm not sure if I
will keep the ratings here I decided to
leave it because like we said this is a
game from 2012 where Coulson is rated
twenty eight hundred and forty three and
now in 2018 where he when he faces this
same opponent Fabiano Khurana for the
World Chess Championship title he is
rated some 1000 points less I think it's
twenty eight thousand thirty five so and
as you can see Caruana is a rated almost
as high as cross and he's - e leu below
Carlsen while in 2012 his Rea he was
rated twenty seven hundred and seventy
two so it seems that this is before
Carson became world champion but later
Carson didn't really try to try to
breach that 2900 Loa and he almost got
very close to it at one point but okay
it's a very nice game at that features
the fringe defense so I'm sure you're
all gonna enjoy it and it features one
very nice move as the title would
suggest so let's check out the game
Caruana has the white pieces and he
opens with E 4 we have e 6 d4 d5 and
nice to see 3 Bishop to b4 so it's the
vinegar variation of the French we have
E 5 at the advanced variation of the win
over
c5 a3 Bishop captures on c3 be captures
on c3 and Knight to e7 here a lot of
moves are possible a lot of most have
been played before like
when 2g4 a4 has been an idea but for
this game
Korona goes Knight to f3 and okay Knight
B to c6 Carson continues his development
we have Bishop to d3 at Bishop to d7
Corona castles mean to c7 rook to e1 and
now Knight to a5 you could try to close
the century immediately with c4 and I've
seen people do this I I for one don't
enjoy this for black after something
like Bishop to f1 white shouldn't have
any problems so which would have closed
central like this black will eat our
Castle kingside and then you will be
able to attack on the king said or he
will perhaps the set of Castle queenside
you already have a semi-open file for
the rook but it is playable you know if
you enjoy a setup like this you should
definitely go for it but okay after Luke
2 e1 we have 90 to 85 my Carlsen and now
comes Knight to g5 of course now black
is definitely not gonna Castle as Corona
has a very nice pressure against the h7
pawn so first night the g6 and now comes
Luke to e3 a very nice rock lift if
Carlson would decide to Castle then it
would become very dangerous on the Kings
side so here with this rook awkwardly
placed on e3 cross and decides to close
the centre with c4 we have c4 Khurana
goes Bishop to e2 and not Knight back to
c6 by cross and as the rook is now kind
of awkwardly placed here on e3 cross and
will remain over the knight via nice to
e7 to f5 Bishop to h5 by Caruana and now
comes a night C to e7 as planned
Queen to g4 and now Bishop to a4 before
going Knight to a5 he wants to see what
Corona will do about this undefended
pawn and c2 so you can either defend it
by bringing the rook to e2 by bringing
the Queen to d1 but Corona decides to do
it with a rook to a2 so the point is not
nicely defended across and brings the
Knight to f5 as planned Knight to f5 and
now look back to e1 by Caruana here
Carlson casts Queen side and now comes
Knight to f3 as there is a really
you know dense concentration of pieces
and the kingside it would be a pretty
poor choice the Castle kingside he
himself or Carlsen so night back to f3
by Caruana and King to be ate a very
nice prophylactic rules and here h4 h4
seems like a rather weird move as you
have Castle kingside you don't want to
do something to provoke a weakness that
black can at some point use to bust open
the Kings side but he does have to do
something about this this bishop is a
very awkwardly placed here the Queen is
G for the night is on f3 if you decided
to go for something like Bishop to g5
for example you attack the rook maybe
you wanna double rooks and the B file as
it is a semi open file rook B to f8
getting the rock out of the way may be
preparing f6 now I hope to be one now h6
attacking the bishop bishop goes back
and now after something like Knight to
e7 g six would be a pretty huge threat
as it would trap the bishop here you'd
have to move the Queen and now after the
Queen moves now you can even go g5 and
it would be a lot of activity for black
well white gets really nothing and
you're not gonna be even able to use the
semi open B file as a black can really
nullify the effect of the double rooks
on the B file simply by playing b6 so h4
making room for the Queen and h3 so the
bishop has a retreat square we have rook
d2 f8 now comes Queen to h3 making room
for the bishop and now Knight goes three
seven queen goes to h2 making room for
the bishop even on h3 and now comes h6
and now g6 wouldn't be that much of a
problem because now as we've said you
can go to g4 and h5 can be met with rush
up to h3 here white would be very
satisfied and now if something like f6
you can go captures on f6 and now after
the Queen's get to trade it off Android
captures on f6 Bishop to f4 check would
be very nice for white King moves and
now Bishop to e5 would would cost black
D exchange
so after this Queen to h2 move we have
h6 by black Bishop to g4 by Carson and
now g5 of course
and wants to bust open the king side but
Caruana does not so he closes it h5 we
have 9th to g7 now preparing f5 and now
comes Knights the d2 and here crossing
goes for it he plays f5 which of course
results in an amp asana via e captures
on f6 and the Queen trade as the Queen's
are x-raying each other over this long
dark square diagonal but it's
interesting
well perhaps it's not interesting I
thought black will bust open the King
said at some point perhaps it would be
better for him not to the trade Queens
for example something like King to a8
first you prepare it and as the white
that doesn't really have all that much
to do with a knight if one of Queen
moves and now as f5 is coming whatever
white plays a let's say 93 and now f5
captures any six characters on f6 it's
not all that clear if the queen is
better on the board for black or off the
board but as s-cross and decided that he
is a very much capable of her playing
without a queen he plays f5 immediately
and ok he captures on f6 on poisson we
have Queen captures on h2 with check
King captures on h2 and now comes rogue
captures on f6 Bishop to f3
and now comes rock to f8 it's well g4
doesn't really do all that much because
now after Bishop captures yes you do
grab the f2 pawn but now white will not
go for the six pawn rather Bishop to f3
will be played and now your rook is
stuck on f2 after you play some move
Knight to f5 the King will come to g1
and now the rock is strapped you will
have to give up the exchange for example
recaptures on f3 Knight captures and you
will simply be down the down in exchange
without any serious compensation so
after Bishop to have three we have roped
h2 e8 doubling up on the F file
Knight to f1 by Carlson and now comes
Knight e to f5 again if you go for
Bishop to be eight immediately to try
and win d h5 pond and knights to g3 can
simply defend it so here Carlsen first
goes night e to f5 he attacks the g3
square so he's preparing to midnight g3
with Knight captures and g3
so we have worshipped
G for now Caruana wants to eliminate the
attacker of the G 3 square Bishop to yet
cousin is now threatening to capture the
H five one and now Bishop captures an f5
as planned Knight captures and now
Knight to e3 again attacking the knight
on f5 but there is no real way to save
the h5 pawn
we have Knight captures Bishop captures
and now cross and captures finally d h5
pawn king to g3 and now butcher back to
g6 so here
Carson is up upon but it will not be all
that easy to convert this into a full
point as it's the two rooks are still on
the board well the four rooks but it's
an opposite colored Bishop end game and
the mmm the bishop to g6 move is very
nice
it still forces why it's the deal with
this week CC to pawn and it's it's it's
a very tough position to play but okay
our rook to be to using the semi open
file now we have h5 by Carson and now f3
as you don't want this F to point to be
a weakness forever
g4 across and car one across and would
very much enjoy opening up the F file
but Khurana would not so Bishop to g5
comes with an attack on the rook on f6
look to f5 attacking the bishop and now
with f4 Caruana is has now closed the DF
file so the Bishop and pawn will
completely block off the doubled rooks
from the F file rook to e8 we have
worked to e2 came to c7 and now rook
back to be one look to f7 and now rook
to h1 rope to h7 came to f2 I think the
b6 and now g3 so now completely closing
the King side the the centre is also
pretty much closed now
they just have to see what will happen
on the Queen side for the moves have
been played so time control has been
reached and one thing I forgot to
mention about this tournament it's a
tournament where a winner was awarded
three points not two points like the
usual and one point for a draw but
rather here a victory was three points
you do want to really make your games
count king to a5 and now comes into e3
the
- f5 kink the d2 rope the c8 and the now
comes bushel to h4 so not really doing
anything for now look to d7 and now rook
the b1 we have looked the c6 cross and
now wants to exchange a pair of rooks
rook e 2 e 1 and now look to b6 offering
a trade route capture screen captures
and rook to be one with check and here
King to c7 if you play King to a5 with
the idea of going after this pawn or
something then white can wait can even
play a four and you're gonna be stuck
here for example you can't capture this
pawn because of rook to a 1 and if you
play something like a six to prepare
capturing this pawn then look to be four
will trap your kinga on a five-wheel
you're not gonna be able to move it the
King will protect the pawn on a four and
nothing will be able to hunt the
dislodge this rook form before it as
it's on a dark square and cousin only
has a light square bishop so not
something you want to do this King to a5
move so King to c7 router King to c1 and
now rook to d6 Michaelson Quinta b2 we
have looked at least six check King to
see one and now rook to a6
seems like you could also trade rooks
here about trading even the last pair of
rooks would be counterproductive as King
kept person B 1 it's an opposite color
bishop endgame and after a few moves
let's say b5 King C 1 a 5 there there's
a really no way after king d2 to make
any breakthroughs you can't play e5
which is the central breakthrough and
you can't play B 4 which is the Queen
side breakthrough so with only these two
breakthroughs at your disposal you will
not be able to actually do anything in
the same game but okay after King to see
one rook to a six by Crossin oh of
course avoid avoiding the rook trade
attacking the a3 pawn now King the be to
simply defending it
Bishop to e4 Bishop to g5 came to d7 and
now Bishop back to h4 King to e8 by
Carlsen came to a 2 now we have B 6 and
now King 2b - came to f7 rook to e1 now
and cousin pushes b5
look back to be 1 we have King to g6 and
now rook to e1 so across and brought his
King all the way to the King side now
King back to f7 and now rook back to a
one look to b6 and now look to be one we
have King to g6 and the now comes King 2
c1
look back to a 6 attacking the a tree
pawn Kings simply defends the pawn king
to f5 and now rook to e1 we have Ruth
the b6 and now comes look back to b1 cos
and pushes a5 and now comes a team to c1
and the bishop to g2 so now cross and
manage to make room for his King but
does he really gain anything by doing
this King the d2 by Caruana and now
across and brings his King into the game
so if you can do this without harming
your king or or running into a checkmate
usually it should be a very nice thing
to do rook to e1 check and here King to
f3 and here rook to e2 by Cora wanna
rook to e3 would be very dangerous
because if rook to e3 check then King
can come to f2 he can go behind the pawn
and after.look to e2 check from g1 rook
e1 checked into h2 white will be able to
go after the h5 pawn but it doesn't
matter for example if Bishop to g4 rook
captures on h5 King to g2 not allowing
any discoveries now after King to see
one black will be able to pull before
and after captures captures captures
captures you will now have busted open
here and as the bishop is attacking the
sea to pawn you will wanna at some point
bring this rook over and attack the c2
pawn so for example look to h8 and now
look to a for kink the b2 blocking rook
to a2 but now you will have this c3
check after white captures you can check
here King moves rook captures on d4 a
king moves and now you will also go
after the seat upon root 2 a rook
captures and c2 and it's not clear if
black can black can really win this what
he would have much greater chances than
then in the position before even
starting this so instead of this rook to
e3 first rope to e2 not allowing Carson
to go anywhere near this h2 square we
have before now by Carlsen pushing this
pawn
a capture some before a capture some
before and now rook to e3 with check now
King to have to look to e to check King
to f3 back rook to e3 check King to have
to look to e to check here carleeee
Khurana played this rook to e3 check for
the third time and now if course some
will repeat a team to f3 it will be a
draw by repetition but Carson all
declines the drop into g1 and okay rook
to e1 check King to H do now by Carson
and now comes C captures on b4 rook
captures on b4 and now rook captures on
e6 here across and blocks with the
Bishop Bishop to b4 he will now want at
some point either attack this C to point
via this maneuver or like we already
mentioned play C to recheck and then if
King captures either bring the rook to
c4 and capture it this way or push
something in some other fashion and here
as the title suggests this is the move
we've all mentioned here rook captures
on e4 it was played and this is in fact
a losing move but as it is a practical
game completely changing the entire
setup of the board it's actually a very
strong move but we're gonna get it back
to this the strongest idea here for a
corona would have been to simply go King
to c1 and continue guarding the be to
square for example rook to a for
preparing rook a to now comes King 2b to
now route before check King goes back
and now row K for King goes back
defending and now if you try and
approach this c2 point with the King for
example you want to make this trip and
then capture this with the bishop it
doesn't work because well after
something like rule d6
king of two now you can push f5 and now
white has all the resources needed for a
draw as he just created a very powerful
passed pawn and of course if you capture
it and look to f6 your bishop cannot
move that they do to the King being on a
file you lose the bishop and it's all
over whatever you play rook captures you
down a piece you will lose this game now
so after a Bishop to b4 Caruana
instead played rook captures on e4 and
okay
Carson has the capture he played D
captures on e4 karana started pushing
his passed pawn with f5
and this is the critical moment of the
game where Carson can win this game but
he has to play the absolute only correct
move so feel free to pause the video
here and try to find this absolute best
move and it's not an easy move to find
so you know give yourself some time it's
a very nice move so for those of you who
were able to do it congratulations you
are really really an an excellent and
game player and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show the move
cost and missed was rocked to b2 and
rook to b2 is a really a hard move to
find because you have to figure out so
many different things like for example
what happens if white simply starts
pushing his bass born
well if f6 then comes King to g2 of
course you have to try and bring your
king into the game and now if f7 simply
looked b8 and now you can no longer
promote this pawn to Queen and you can
always go behind the pawn capture it and
then you have a rook against the bishop
and the bishop cannot come to e7 regard
it as then you would capture the g3 pawn
give up your look for this pawn and then
with the two passports and the King side
you would be able to win this on the
other hand after this look to be to move
that was not played after f6 for example
you don't have to go and play f7 but you
can go King to eat sorry
you can go instead King to e3 but then
you get rook captures and c2 King
captures here and now comes rook to f2
and now with the rook being on f2 the
the phone is blocking the King from
approaching the d3 Square and also your
guarding against this pawn being pushed
to f7 so after something like d5 trying
to pull the D pawn now c3 will be
winning if King approaches at c2 you're
threatening to promote your pawn also
the rook from f2 is guarding the pawn
and if Bishop to g5 preventing the pond
from queening then comes King captures
and g3 finally and of course if you
start pushing your deep on then there's
this very nice rook captures on f6 and
now you will either you will either
capture this point and then you will
lose this point and you have a winning
and
or you will capture the rook and then
this comes with a queen and the d7
doesn't help you even though d8 is
guarded because of Queen d1 check King
moves and Queen captures and of course
lastly but not leastly after rook to be
- you might say but what about King to
c3 surely that - works I mean your rook
is under attack now not really because
of III and now you either capture the
rook and after E - you can't stop
promotion or even better if you don't
capture the rook then the pawn this
point is covering d3 this point is
covering d2 the two points create a wall
against the white king the white king
cannot approach the past upon it is the
fastest of pawns and it is a winning
game for black so this is a move cross
and missed but you know it's it's a very
hard it's a very easy move to miss it's
okay
now after this fi move by Caruana cross
and did not find this rook to be too
rather he played King to g2 but now it's
a bit different Caruana gets King to e3
and here cross and did go for Luke to be
2 but now rook to b2 is a losing move
because being down a tempo means that
really much in this position but
interestingly as we're gonna go back to
this position to show that there was
more poison in the position Caruana
pushed d5 and now we have row characters
in situ d6 c3 preparing roof to d2 but
now comes d7 roof to d2 the rook is now
guarded and now comes d8 with Queen rook
captures Bishop captures and now h4g
Capra's on h4 g3 now pushing the
passport but now this f 6c - now comes
King to d2 preventing the point from
queening and now III with Czech team
captures in c2 now comes Ito and now you
are very close to winning your first
game against Magnus Carlsen ever so it
would be it would be a shame if you
would go and prevent to this point from
Keaney queening with King to d2 because
now King to f1 would again be winning
there is no stopping point to e1 now but
Khurana plays the absolute best move
after E - he played Bishop to a5
blocking off this point from queening
and now there's really nothing to do
here it was in this position that magnus
carlsen resigned at the game and Fabiana
karana got his first victory ever
against Magnus Carlsen and it's it's
very interesting because after King to
f1 now you can simply push f7 and now if
e1 Queen gush of character screen
captures you can simply promote to a
queen and g2 does nothing as you can
simply even give up give up the Queen
for this pawn and start pushing your H
point this point will now get promoted
and white wins but I mentioned the debt
after that critical moment that cross
and missed that after karana pushed f5
cross and played King to g2 instead of
rook to be - but even after this King to
g2 and King to e3 that karana played
still across in her cousin could have
drawn the game with rook the b3 check
here a very nice move because now of
course if you capture then pawn captures
there is no stopping this pawn after
King comes here you can simply play III
and now this comes with check either
this pawn will Queen or this pawn will
Queen
so after loop to b3 check you can't
accept see characters on b3 you have to
play King captures on e4 and now it's a
very long but forced variation also
extremely easy to miss Rooke the c3 the
five row captures and c2 and now d6 c3
similar to what was played in the game
but now Bishop to g5 rook to e1 rook to
e2 check King d5 h for now creating a
passed pawn G cap resonate for and now
g3 f6 came to h3 and now f7 wrote the d2
with check a very important move because
now if Bishop captures then this pawn is
already on d2 and will queen with check
very important so now kink the c6g to
another pawn is ready to Queen but now
f8 Queen
we have g1 Queen now black is already up
in material and the white will have no
other choice but to go for Queen to f3
check now you cannot go King to h2
because you're getting checkmated if
came to h2 then Bishop to f4 check King
to g2
Quinta g3 and then what you're gonna
lose the Queen or even better you can
just grab with the Bishop Bishop checks
King to h3 and now you're getting
checkmated Bishop e5 check King captors
on h4 and Bishop to f6 this will be
checkmate but even even without
something like this for example after
Queen g3 check King cannot go to h2 you
will have to block with the Queen White
will have to trade Queens and now d7
will be met with rook to d1 you still
can't put the seed C pawn as the dark
square Bishop covers both D 2 and C 1 so
after da Queen you will simply capture
it and after Bishop captures you will
now push c2 Bishop g5 c1 this comes with
cherub Bishop captures and now King will
capture on h4 and this is a draw by
insufficient material obviously so yeah
a really really amazing stuff
after this f5 move by car wanna cross
and mrs. rugby - and then after after
after he plays King G - he didn't misses
it again well he couldn't win anymore
but he could have drawn by force but
this is what happens here Carson was
pretty much better for the entire game
but he was not satisfied with the draw
he was pushing pushing pushing and well
in the end of course he pushed too far
and ended up losing this game which is
his first official loss in a tournament
game against Fabiano Khurana so I really
an intense game from 2012 bilbao some of
you may have never seen it so i do
really do hope you enjoyed it and we
don't have a couple of nice interesting
photos and stats from this tournament
these are the final standings so as you
can see cross and won the tournament
with 17 points the the exact same as
Caruana has 17 points followed by lemon
arunya and Sergey Carrick in
Vishwanathan Anand and Paco Vallejo but
it's also interesting that cost and in
Caruana had to go into a tiebreaker
I will also show more games between
cross and Caruana from this tournament
as a warm-up for the 2018 World Chess
Championship so after I after I make
those videos I will put links to them in
the description below so you can enjoy
that as well and we
have a couple of nice photos here is a
nice handshake from Coulson and Caruana
before at the start of the tiebreaks
very nice photo I don't know who the
photos belong to as the official link is
in the description below it's from Chaz
NomCom but they posted a link to the
official page which is the Bilbao
official page which no longer exists
so that's kind of unfortunate but you
know if any of you have any idea who the
photos belong to do sure and I will
share it in the description below also
we have a nice photo of Carson holding a
nice boat model and also he has a very
nice hat there is young Kuryakin behind
him and also what appears to be
Vishwanathan Anand right behind Carson
and also here we have a photo of all of
the participants of the tournament there
you have Parker who is wanna Tanana and
Sarah Kerrigan and magnus carlsen 11
Aryan and Fabiano Corwin all the way to
the right you can see all the players
who received some sort of gift boxes and
cross and received this very nice hat
and and a model boat which is very nice
if any of you know the story behind the
boat also do share you know I would
enjoy learning about that as well and I
have to say I really like crossing suit
it's it's a very nice color I would say
it's a of a brown red color but I'm sure
that this color has some sort of a
sophisticated name so I do hope you
enjoyed all of this I would like to
thank Martin Reinhardt eichhorn Vincent
Berlinski George Holloway Jason Whittle
and John Ernst for a contribution to my
channel thank you what I really
appreciated as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here think all for
watching and I will see you soon
hopefully with some more interesting
content and also a short announcement
Dingley rain has broken Mikkel tells a
record of 95 consecutive undefeated
games in a row he now drew drew a game
his 95th game in a row against onigiri
and then he also drew a game against
Maxine Varsha holograph
so that's 96 games undefeated for now so
he still has to go to some 105 to become
number one in this regard but you know
it seems that it's definitely going his
way so thank you all and I'll see you
soon